[Music]
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Kristen
starts this hour in Tulsa Oklahoma hi
Kristen how are you I'm good how are you
doing better than we deserve what's up
in your world um well thank you for
taking my call um so my husband of 16
years uh passed away two months
ago I'm so sorry yes
y'all are young how old was he um I'm 39
uh we have five children and he was
46 wow so what happened um well he had
been battling uh cancer for um three
years and then he had a really intensive
radiation treatment to his liver and
then he had some neck issues so it was
on lots of pharmaceuticals so with with
that and the disease and the treatment
his his body just gave out
so it happened very quick yeah thank you
I appreciate that so um I never paid a
bill in 16 years and so I'm left to
Steward our five children and um all of
our finances and um I want a steward as
well um but I'm feeling uh zero
confidence without him leading in this
area yeah he's been in he was in charge
of it for all of that time yes 100% in
charge how old are your babies uh my
oldest is 15 and my youngest is
four so was there insurance that came
about yes and that is actually my
primary question is so well he had a few
life insurance policies and I was going
to tell you what debts we we had and to
see if it's better I remember him
telling me a long time ago to take the
insurance money and pay off the
mortgages but I know we've refinanced
since then and obviously situations it's
just different now so I I wanted a
nonbiased opinion on what would be the
wrong place for that we're extremely
bied we're we're biased to try to help
you so what how much insurance was there
okay it was it's going to be about
720,000 how much debt do you have so we
have three mortgages um our primary
mortgage we the value is
$496 and we the payoff is
267 now our rate is
2.65 you said the value of the house is
500 yes and you owe two two what
six7 okay do you have any other debt
other than that mortgage you said you
had three mortgages yes so we have two
rental properties actually um we net
about $1,200 a month on what is the
value what's the uh equities in those
properties what give me the value of
rental property number one and the
mortgage on rental property number okay
it's 319 319 value and the mortgage on
that one is is 109 okay and the other
one is valued at what two 31 okay and uh
the value is
what I'm sorry 231 8 we we owe 88 on it
88 okay oh wow so you got a little bit
of equity not a ton uh in both of them
but you could pay off everything and
still have a substantial amount of money
left yeah yes okay now who was handling
all the tenants and the landlording he
was yes he was okay so we have two
complicated things here that you have to
learn uh in a crem course
how to handle the the monthly personal
finance issues at home and learn how to
be a landlord yes
okay which I do have a lot of family
here I don't care um I mean it's nice it
they're there but they're not going to
do it for you they're not going to do it
for you well do you want to be a
landlord um no not necessarily I the
good thing is I mean the rent you've
been a full-time Mom all this time yes
and I actually just got my master's last
year and I am actually a
counselor cool okay so you have the
ability to create some income I do okay
all right and so I do have I'm I'm GNA
have social security um and I have a
better idea now what that's going to
look like um for me and the kids
okay Jay jump in anywhere you want here
but I'm pretending like at this moment
that you're my little sister MH okay yes
I love that and if you were my little
sister what would I tell you to do I
personally love real estate I own a
bunch of it but it sounds to me like you
don't need landlording on top of five
kids and trying to learn how to handle
money for the first time in 16 years
that's what I would say so I'm probably
selling these two houses for one reason
and one reason only and that's to
simplify your life okay your life
doesn't need to be any more compc ated
in the middle of mhm the pain and the
new found stress of having to handle
some other stuff plus you said they cash
flow 1,200 a month combined yeah that's
I you can go out and make that and way
more like I don't think it's do you see
what I'm saying so if you were to sell
those take the money from those and pay
off your home you'd have $700,000 to
invest and sit down with a smartvestor
pro with some mutual funds create an
investment account you've got a pile of
money coming in for social security for
the five kids you can use that money the
money you earn as a counselor and a
little bit of money off the 700 and
easily mathematically by by the math
would be easy not the life but the math
would be you could easily take care of
your family yes yes and that's really
what I want I don't want you dealing
with some tenant okay yeah I do have on
my car I owe
20,000 pay it off today okay what else
do you have is that it that's it that's
it it was a threeyear just and never
borrow never borrow money again okay
that's rule number one because you have
a paid for house a paid for car five
kids and a big old pile of money and
you're going to live on less than you
make so that this is sustainable into
perpetuation okay and then you've taken
care of yourself now here's what we're
going to do okay you you mentioned
Steward which is typically a word by
used by people of Faith so you're a
person of faith I assume 100% okay so
are we and my book yes that my heavenly
father gave me he told me to take care
of widows so you're going to be taking
care of we're going to put you into
Financial Peace University into every
dollar and I'm going to assign one of
our Ramsey coaches to you to get you up
and get you trained and help you get
sustainable with your knowledge and it's
all on us thank you so much thank you so
much Merry Christmas honey Merry
Christmas I'm so sorry you're going
through but we're going to walk with you
okay thank you so much you hold on the
team will pick up and get you taken care
of create your free every doll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life